My name is Erdem.
I am a fashion designer, and we're here at the Marianne North Gallery in Kew Gardens.
And I'm on my way to meet Judd Crane, who is the womenswear director at Selfridges.
Hi Judd.
Hey Erdem.
Glad we could be here today.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
It was very much the starting point for my spring/summer collections.
So I thought it would be a nice place to walk you through my inspiration.
Can we have a look?
Yeah, let's go!
I really, if I'm being totally honest, looked more at the actual botanical studies...
...towards the very end of the collection.
The starting point was really this idea of this woman and who she was,...
...and this idea of this strong, independent person who had a great sense of adventure,...
...and also this idea of something becoming quite undone.
I loved the idea of Victorian strictness,...
...and there's certainly a kind of buttoned-upness to the collection.
But then also contracted with something that feels really kind of undone,...
...and she became more and more wild as the show progressed.